[Music]
i'll be honest i don't know if you're a
one spot mainly no and the only reason
why is because the first photo of you
looks nothing like you do now that is
true
[Music]
i go with tinder and bumble but tinder i
feel like i get a lot more attention on
for me bumble it's mostly the quality of
people that you meet
this is me
you know i like the first picture you
should leave a comment if you work on
being a better person for yourself your
friends family society all well-being
your quirky goofy self i like that this
is me reading to my brother's dog smart
to put a dog i'm very smart
very smart
so you know candid you're verified got
the verified check we've got the
vaccinated sticker gotta be vaccinated
great photos
gotta rock gotta rock the dark sabers
gotta rock the dark saber and the bio is
i just moved to long beach i need
someone to show me around
i'm honestly just a big nerd and look i
have no reason to be on here so let's
skip the small talk and just go on a
date i feel like nick and rick are like
well established people who know who
they are and i feel like when it comes
to dating that's
a necessity all right my profile
tomorrow or this tattoo apprentice
yeah this is a great first picture sorry
thank you
do your chin yeah oh my god
gentlemen by day philosopher by night
lover by choice rebel by fate
currently
currently apprenticing at a tattoo shop
i spend all my free time finding scenic
views on my motorcycle pro i'll cook for
you con i'll eat all the food i cooked
for you
[Laughter]
i'm honest
this is my profile it's on hinge um i
first began with like a prompt like toby
maguire is the best spider-man and then
i'm a software engineer and this is just
a picture i i put like after graduation
me and my friend were drinking champagne
in front of our school library and then
this is just a picture of like
me and this dog found in peru this could
be us
like
that's cool
and it is just a magic trick i did yeah
wait what
oh
yeah i mean it's
it's it's in reverse but like it's the
same it's like ace to a queen but right
so it's tyler i got a modeling picture
right you know uh lactose intolerant but
willing to indulge dairy with the right
person
[Music]
yeah right swipe right if you want and
then it's got the little you know
tiki-taki thing where it's like
okay if we think about it logically
these two are software engineers if you
are just looking for someone to take you
on a date who can afford to take you on
a nice date software engineer yeah i
don't know about that because i think
it's more like you know they're looking
for someone they can see themselves with
and you know i think like
occupation it can be important but it's
like
i i feel like you know you guys have a
ton of fun pictures where it's like man
i want to be friends with you let's go
let's hang out after this you know what
i'm i'm kind of i feel like i'm pretty
locked into that number two spot
i feel like i'm right there
i feel like i
bio's got everything girls like taking
photos i i'm very photogenic
i'm gonna be honest
you've got the smarts and you've got the
adventure aspect you've got the artist
style the motorcycle all that i will
happily take the fifth position because
my bio sucks
you gotta you ain't gotta do that to
yourself bro hey if you wanna move it
that's on you i just thought the rest of
the group brought a little bit more than
just a star wars loving nerd okay i'm
going to put myself
here
i'll put my oh
no
dude dude i wanted to put white salt i
what i wanted to put myself at four now
i look like a dick you know what you
want me to move it over to the number
one
you know i'll take the number one spot
if y'all don't really want it i'll i'll
take it you know if you guys don't want
it you know i don't really feel
comfortable like putting myself you know
too high in front of like other people
just because i think you know everyone
is different i'll be honest i don't know
if you're a one spot mainly no and the
only reason why is because the first
photo of you looks nothing like you do
now that is true you look nothing like
that that's what i bring to the table
that's what i bring to the table i got
so many looks that i can incorporate
into my life i want to put mario i want
to do it i'm just saying tomorrow this
is your phone ryan okay
i think like like that i feel like this
is
i feel like i feel like maro is like
super duper i mean like we didn't touch
mine that's cool yeah i like it
i was actually thinking you two should
go first just because i feel like you
guys are well established and
know who you are and
not not saying that you guys don't but
the phone doesn't fit there
damn make a move damn damn that was a
big move
the outline that i laid out was
definitely not what i
wanted well especially with tyler it's
mostly about
dateability and not
[Music]
good things um i would say occupation we
always look at what they do um we look
at their pictures shirtless mirror
selfies that's
something i wouldn't swipe right on okay
let's see what they picked for most
tyler
it's good
a lot of emojis
the last
selfie is
kind of like he's into himself okay next
one
he's verified if we go out with any
stranger we just like to know that it's
actually them he's into music black
lives matter dancing cooking mental
health awareness
well he likes the jonas brothers i like
the jonas brothers okay
let's see ricky okay that's a
conversation starter software engineer
at google
the best way to ask me out is by saying
i like you you're cute let's go on a
date that's cute well these are good
pictures
okay
ed
let's debate this topic tobi maguire is
the best friend man agreed oh a magic
trick that's cute
okay mauro 26
tattoo artist
i'm known for my ability to gaze into
your soul okay very deep
the tinder one we might have to move
down i prefer bumble or hinge
tinder seems very hook up it's 20 21. i
don't know the profile doesn't really
attract me okay let's put ed here
let's move him down
i'm rearranging everything good
occupation good pictures
and the video helps for ricky
he's very positive good pictures as well
actually
you might have to put him down his
problems are better
yeah i think nick
should be in the middle he's as tender
but he just moved to long beach so i can
see why for morrow
i think the my ability to gaze into your
souls a little too deep for me we're
just on a dating app yeah okay
[Music]
so i put ricky first
ed second
nick third
marlo fourth and tyler last i'm sorry
[Music]
that's a big that's a big jump did you
place yourself first uh
i
did i yeah
i feel like no one was taking that first
spot no offense but you kind of come off
as like boy
see that's that's the thing yeah i i i
get that a lot actually i think for me
as a college student that's what girls
are really into that's why i match a lot
i think but all those people really want
is just like a fling or something and i
guess my only question would be i know
these two are using hinge i know you
were using bumble and i know you use
tinder does the app make a difference it
does it depends what the girl's looking
for on my end i don't think girls look
for hookups i mean there are a few girls
that might
and i would think they gravitate towards
tinder i'm just going to delete tinder
after this now
i came into it thinking it was more of
look bases but you can have good looks
but it doesn't mean you're hubby
material i think it really changed my
perspective of how you know the dating
app world is that i was a confidence
booster for sure i think i was
approaching dating apps with the
intention of being a bit more attention
seeking rather than
actually attempting to go on a date with
somebody and i think the biggest thing
is we need to kind of abolish this idea
of hookup culture and get back to just
humans connecting with other humans
[Music]
you